HUSAIN BENGALL:
Welcome, everyone.
How are you doing?
AUDIENCE: Great!
HUSAIN BENGALL: Great.
Let's talk about
engineering cinematic VR
or, in other words, immersive
VR video experiences.
I'm Husain, a product
manager working on VR video.
And today we're going to
talk to you about some
of the challenges
associated with the medium,
focusing primarily on
delivery and playback.
Let's start with why we
think VR video is important.
VR video has the power to
immerse you and transport you
to events, places,
and moments and make
you feel like you're there.
It's a kind of immersion
that traditional video
on a rectangular screen
can't quite get you.
For a start, there's too
much of the real world
visible on the periphery.
With VR video, your
entire field of view
is occupied with
nothing but the content.
If I were watching
this scene in VR,
I might actually feel like
the horse was looking directly
at me.
That sort of immersion you
just can't get by watching TV.
Now, in the real world
I can look around,
and VR video enables that too.
In order for it to feel like
I can reach out and touch
that horse, though, I need
to be able to perceive
a sense of depth
and scale, and that
comes through stereoscopic
3D in which each eye sees
a slightly different image.
Take a look at the
horse and focus
on its face and the
window right behind it,
and watch as I toggle the
image your left eye would
see with the image your
right eye would see.
That small but
important difference
is exactly how we perceive
depth in the real world.
It's what makes near things look
near and far things look far.
Adding this into 360 video
is incredibly immersive
and it is almost as important
as the ability to look around.
So far we've only
talked about video,
and we've still come a long
way from that flat TV screen
I showed you at the beginning.
However, we haven't even
approached audio yet.
In a stable I would
expect to be able to hear
the horses around me,
and if we did that
through traditional
audio effects
it might feel incomplete.
Here's why.
Turn your head and
look around the room.
You'll notice that
sounds around the room,
like that fan for instance,
sound slightly different
as you turn your head.
And that actually enables
you, subconsciously,
to be able to localize where
that sound was coming from
even if your eyes were closed.
We can recreate that
in VR through the use
of spatial audio.
Now let's add all of
this together-- 360 video
with stereoscopic
3D, watched in VR
so you can perceive
it, and spatial audio,
and we think you have
all the elements needed
for cinematic VR experiences,
or VR video, that
can truly transport you.
At Google our mission is
VR for everyone, which also
means VR video for everyone.
We wanted to find a way to
overcome the engineering
challenges associated with
the medium in a way that
makes these experiences
available to as many people as
possible.
We started by building Jump,
or VR video creation platform.
Consists of a camera
spec that partners
are helping bring to market,
an assembler that takes away
all the pain of
manual stitching,
and finally a way
to play back that VR
video alongside spatial
audio on a platform
that you all are
already familiar with.
You can watch many of these
incredible experiences
on YouTube today.
But that's not all.
Behind the scenes,
we've been working
to make playback of these
types of videos even better.
To talk to you about that,
I'd like to invite up
on stage Andrew Scherkus.
Come on up, Andrew.
ANDREW SCHERKUS: Thanks, Husain.
Hey, everyone.
I am Andrew Scherkus
and I'm going
to talk a little bit today
about some of the tech
we've been building to really
create that immersive VR video
experience.
But what do I really mean when
I'm saying immersive VR video?
Well, in our opinion, it comes
down to a few key ingredients.
First of all, you want to
have as much resolution
right in front of
where you're looking.
This really creates that
first important ingredient
of making it feel like
you're right there.
But, as Hussein mentioned,
we're huge believers in stereo.
And so we'll need to
double that resolution just
to actually give you
that stereo imagery,
because without stereo, we
don't think it really counts.
It doesn't really feel
like you're there.
And finally, and perhaps
most importantly,
no buffering at all.
It's one thing to have your
phone out and be waiting
for like a video to load.
When it's glued to your face,
it is a horrifying experience.
So we need to be really
bandwidth conscious
and worry about connectivity.
So with that in mind, let's
walk through some steps
on how would we actually
create immersive video.
Well, we're working with
360 video, so, first of all,
we have to pick some
way to represent.
So we'll pick a
sphere-to-plane projection
to represent our video.
We'll increase the resolution
until we're fully filling up
the screen in your optics so
that you can see everything
in full fidelity.
And then last we're
going to double it,
because we love stereo.
So let's dive into
that first piece,
that sphere-to-plane projection.
It turns out if you've
ever looked at a map,
this is a pretty
familiar concept.
Seen here is your good,
old-fashioned equirectangular
projection of the Earth.
And even though this has been
used for quite some time,
it's actually a pretty
useful format today
and is actually used
for 360 cameras,
both for images and video alike.
Here's a sample
frame and, sure, it's
a little funky looking
at the top and bottom,
but you get a good sense
for what's going on, right?
I'm over there on
the left and I'm
reaching towards the camera.
And my fingers kind
of get all mushed up,
but you get it, right?
You can kind of figure
out what's going on.
And 360 cameras produce
this format today,
and streaming video
sites like YouTube
accept this format today.
You could even take this and
put it into a video editing app
and you could kind of stitch
together a basic film.
It kind of works.
But let's do some back
of the envelope math
to figure out just how big an
equirectangular video would
have to be in order to give
you that first requirement
of really filling up
the maximum resolution.
So let's assume we
have a 1440p display.
It's pretty common on
high-end smartphones.
We'll divide it by 2
to get 1,280 pixels.
We'll assume, just to
make the math easy,
you're around 100 degrees
field of view for your headset.
This gives us about
12.8 pixels per degree.
Then you multiply it by the
sphere around the horizon,
which is 360 by 180,
and this kind of
gives us an approximation
to really hit
that maximum resolution
we're talking about.
So to put that in terms
of, like, megapixels
just for comparison, this brings
us to 10.6 megapixels for mono.
But, you know, I'm
really driving this home.
We love stereo, so
we've got to double it.
That puts us at 21.2.
And, for reference,
a 4K stream is 8.3.
So, we're way over budget.
Not only is this going to be
really hard for a hardware
decoder to do, it's
also really hard
for like a multi-core
desktop workstation to do.
And not only that,
but I feel like you're
going to be seeing a lot
of that buffering spinner.
So this is not
really going to work.
This is where equirectangular
just like totally
falls flat on its face.
But, luckily, we don't
have to stick to it, right?
Once you upload it
to, like, YouTube,
we can work with that, right?
We can work with
these big files.
To cover sort of why
projections are challenging,
it really boils down
to the math behind
sphere-to-plane projections.
If I were to tell
you to take an orange
and unpeel it and try to make
it look like a rectangle,
you actually can't do it
without flattening and squishing
and stretching that peel.
So what that means
is the visual quality
starts to change
based on where you've
stretched in order to
make that rectangle.
So if the user looks in some
areas, it'll look better,
and when they look in other
areas, it looks worse.
So when we looked
at this, we really
wanted to consider all the
best and worst qualities
of any given projection.
Let's go back to Earth.
So there is a huge,
glaring, obvious clue
on the map of any Earth that
kind of really gives you
a hint on where the
best quality might be,
and it's at the poles, right?
Antarctica is
ginormous but it's not
that ginormous of a continent.
Correspondingly, the
worst visual quality's
along the equator.
If we consider 360 imagery, this
doesn't make a lot of sense,
right?
My fingers are getting
a lot of pixels
and the ceiling's getting
a ton of pixels too,
but where everyone
is standing, they're
not getting their
fair share of pixels.
That's not a great solution.
So going back to
what I mentioned
earlier, what if we use
something else, such as cube
maps?
You may have seen this in games
any time you've walked around
and you wanted to have
the sky appear something
or to have
environmental effects.
You'll immediately
notice that Antarctica,
looking a lot more regular sized
compared to everything else.
This is already a
great first clue
that, hey, things might be
a little bit more uniform.
But it starts to
get tricky, right?
With equirectangular
we were really easily
able to figure out that,
OK, the top and the bottom
gets the most pixels and
the middle gets the least.
How do we analyze
projections such as cube map?
And, expanding upon that, how
do we analyze any arbitrary
projection?
So we built some analysis tools
to really deeply understand
this problem.
This is the spectrum
that we're going
to use to sort of describe
these projections.
On one end, we've got too
much upscaling going on.
This means that if
someone were to look
in a region that's kind of
more reddish or orangeish,
it'll be blurry.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
we have too much downscaling,
which typically isn't always
a bad thing.
But if you think about it
in the sense of bandwidth
and trying to really, like,
nail the right quality
without serving too
much, you don't actually
want too much
downscaling going on.
It's a wasteful thing.
So there is a sweet spot and
it's for a given resolution
for a given hardware
display and optics combo.
Let's take a look at what
equirectangular looks
like with our tool.
Right off the bat, we
see at the top and bottom
we've got that blue.
I'm sure it looks great.
I'm sure my feet look
wonderful, but that's not really
the point of 360 video.
If we were to look at
cube maps in this tool,
we start to see a more
interesting, you know,
colorful picture.
And, ironically enough,
we represent these images
in equirectangular
format because they're
just human-friendly.
You'll start to notice that the
best visual quality when using
cube maps are along the edges.
This means that if you took
a 360 video in a cube map
and I were to try
to quiz you on,
hey, where to look
for the best quality,
you would actually tilt
your head to the left
and tilt it up.
And you would look
in one of the corners
because that's actually
where the best image
quality is hiding.
Correspondingly, the
worst areas of a cube map
are right in the
middle of each face.
When we started looking
at pictures like this,
we were like, I
wonder if there's
something else we could use.
And we did some digging
and it turns out
that people have been looking
at projections for a long time.
And there was one that
was used with actual space
imagery in the '70s and we
called it equiangular cube map.
The basic concept
is just to take
some of those, like, extra
pixels that were in the corners
and sides and just
kind of spread
them around a little bit more.
We end up with actually a much
more uniform representation
of the full sphere.
When we test this with
users, every single person
was able to tell.
They're like, yep,
that looks better.
I don't know why, but
I just like it better.
That made us feel pretty good.
So it doesn't quite get
us there though, right?
We've been only looking at
very uniform representations,
very uniform projections.
And this is a pretty
good solution.
You can use this
for images or video
to get that really nice, uniform
resolution everywhere you look,
and it's a good candidate
for offline or unreliable
bandwidth.
You only need to create
one of these videos
and just buffer it for
as long as you want.
But it doesn't hit
that sweet spot
we were talking about earlier.
So how are we
going to get there?
Where can we really
just leverage
the user gaze and the
user view direction
to deliver as many pixels
as possible to where
they're looking?
With projections,
you can actually
represent them as 3D geometry.
So with equirectangular,
you can map it
to a tessellated 3D sphere.
With a regular cube map,
you can map it to a cube.
Kind of makes sense.
And with something like
equiangular cube map,
you can map that to
a tessellated cube.
But what if we
went with something
a little bit more exotic?
What would that look like
in our analysis tool?
We were kind of curious.
So, for fun, let's just
take a look at pyramid.
Right off the bat,
it's pretty colorful.
And you'll notice that the
best visual quality is right
smack dab in the middle.
This is pretty awesome.
And that things kind of
just gradually taper off,
and that's not
necessarily a bad thing.
This is a simulation of what
that original frame would
look like.
I'm nice and clear.
My co-presenter
Dillon, we would have
to generate a new video to
actually sort of represent him
because, in the previous
version, he was kind of blurry.
And, same, we'd have to generate
a new video with a new pyramid
if we wanted to focus on the
group of people to the right.
So we like to call this class
of projections directional
projections.
They're very directed
towards a particular region
and they place the
highest resolution
within a particular
field of view.
On the flip side, like
I just illustrated,
it does require
multiple versions.
If there are multiple
regions of interest,
you have to generate
multiple videos.
And to keep up with
that immersion,
we really want to have low
latency and minimal buffering,
because if it takes
a couple seconds
and I'm seeing blurriness
over here, that kind of kills
the whole experience.
So to kind of summarize all of
this talk about projections,
we really feel like
there isn't necessarily
a silver bullet here.
It really depends on the
content, where people
are looking, your
bandwidth, and actually
the characteristics
of the hardware.
So with that in mind,
it really kind of starts
to make you think
about, well, how
do you tie this into
existing video streaming
sites like YouTube today?
And we found it
really helpful to look
at how this was solved with
multiple resolution streams,
or adaptive streaming.
Here's a super simple example
with just a standard definition
and high definition stream.
Based on your bandwidth
or your device,
you would either get switched
up to a high definition stream
or back to a standard
definition stream.
And if your device actually
can't even play HD content,
it also doesn't really
necessarily mean
it makes a lot of sense
to serve you HD content.
And same with if your
bandwidth all of a sudden start
to get a little
unreliable, we'd want
to switch you back because
we don't like buffering.
Adaptive streaming's a
really great solution
at minimizing any
instances of buffering.
With this model in mind, we
actually kind of applied it
to our whole notion around there
not being a single projection
to rule them all, and we call it
adaptive projection streaming.
We really notice that there
are instances where you really
do want that uniform projection,
notably to avoid buffering.
But there are also
instances where you really
want that sharp focus in a
particular area, whether it's
due to the content or whether
it's just due to the user
just looking in a
particular direction.
We actually find
tying things together
this way makes it really easy
to reason about and solve
a lot of different use cases
because, again, we really care
about delivering
as much of VR video
to as many people as possible.
So we're actually building
this in YouTube today.
And even if a lot of this kind
of projection stuff was like,
oh, I really don't want
to deal with pyramids
or this echo-angular
something or other,
like, that's totally
fine because we
have equirectangular.
It's going to be here
for, like, awhile, right?
The map didn't go anywhere.
You can upload your
content to YouTube.
We'll kind of take
care of the rest
and make it look the right
kind of shape and size
to deliver the goal
of really immersive VR
video for everyone.
That only really covers
the video aspect though.
I'm going to bring
up Dillon here.
He's going to talk to us a
little bit more about audio.
DILLON COWER: Thanks, Andrew.
So Andrew talked
to you about what
we're working on to improve the
visual quality of cinematic VR
experiences.
That's only 50%
of the experience.
So today I'm going to be
talking to you about what we're
doing to bring awesome
spatial audio to cinematic VR
experiences for everyone.
Our ears are highly
complex instruments,
taking in a vast amount
of information every point
in time.
And as such, they're a critical
tool for VR storytelling.
VR needs spatial audio.
We really believe that.
So what is spatial audio?
What it boils down
to is audio that
fully represents the sound
space around the listener.
It allows the listener to
answer a couple of questions--
where is the sound coming from
and what environment am I in?
So spatial audio should
have three properties.
It should have a
location in space,
it should capture
the environment,
and finally it should
immerse the listener.
At the end of the
day, you should
feel like you've
teleported somewhere else
and everything should look
and sound correct and amazing.
We really think that
you can't feel presence
without hearing it.
So let's think for a second
about the bare minimum amount
of information that we would
need to stream to the client
for them to hear special audio.
Well, humans have two ears.
And in VR, we're
generally using headphones
to listen to the audio.
So maybe we can
just stream that.
We can stream two
channels of audio.
So, in theory, you could
store a complex representation
of the spatial audio
seen on the server,
and then render that in
real time on the server
depending on where the
listener is viewing,
and then stream
that to the client.
And this is a pretty
well-understood problem
from the streaming
point of view.
It's equivalent to
streaming stereo audio.
However, in reality,
this doesn't work out.
There's latency everywhere in
the stack and audio encoding,
audio decoding, audio
output, network transmission,
and so on.
What this adds up to is
just a poorer VR experience.
So we know that we need
to find a representation
for spatial audio to
send to the client.
We know that we can't just
pre-render two channels
of audio and send that.
We need to represent
the full audio scene.
So let's start off by taking a
look at surround sound audio,
5.1, 7.1, traditional
speaker layouts.
And surround sound
audio is based
around this idea of each
channel of audio corresponding
to a physical speaker.
So for 5.1 audio,
you'll have six channels
of audio for six
physical speakers--
front left, front right,
center, and so on.
However, surround sound is built
for front-facing experiences
like home cinema or theaters.
And this is great
for that application
where most of the
action's in front of you
and there's not so
much behind you.
And so the speaker
layouts are oriented
toward this, with more
speakers in the front
and fewer in the back.
However, for VR
this isn't ideal.
We care just as much
about audio behind you
as we do audio in front of you.
And, in addition to
that, speaker layouts
for surround sound audio are
generally pretty horizontal.
There's not a lot of
vertical resolution there,
and in 360 video we care about
everything in the sphere.
So let's now talk about
object-based audio.
And the idea here is
to represent everything
in the same, for each source.
We're going to take
mono audio along
with metadata
about that source--
its position,
size, speed, shape,
and so on, as well
as characteristics
about the environment, such
as reverb, reflections,
geometry as complex as we want.
But this sounds like an
audio engine for games,
and it basically
amounts to that.
And this is great for
interactive experiences.
We're depending on user input.
You want to change the
way that things sound,
you might want to
play a sound over here
or you might want to
attenuate something depending
on where the viewer's looking.
And this is also great for
post-production and mastering
where you want the highest
fidelity spatial audio
representation you can have.
Now, for streaming,
we love predictability
and we love consistency
in data rate.
It allows us to adapt better
to the user's bandwidth
and, in general,
we just like that.
And for VR as well,
we like predictability
and we like consistency
in performance.
We want each of our frame times
to be as close as possible.
However, with
object-based audio,
as the number of sources
in the scene increases
or as the environment
changes, more data is required
and this isn't
good for streaming.
So finally let's take
a look at ambisonics.
And ambisonics is a full sphere
spatial audio representation
dating back to the '70s, where
it was far ahead of its time.
And the idea behind
ambisonics is
opposite to object-based audio.
Object-based audio, you store
everything about the scene.
With ambisonics, you're
collapsing that down
into an approximation
of the scene.
So you don't want to
store the entire scene,
you just want to store some
kind of approximation of it.
And this is great for
streaming because it
hits those points of
consistency and predictability.
So let's take a look at
first-order ambisonics, which
is the initial
version of ambisonics.
The idea is similar
to mid-side stereo,
which is a technique used
in the audio industry.
And the idea behind
mid-side stereo,
you take two
microphones and then
you sum them in different
ways to create a narrow
or a wide stereo image.
So first-order ambisonics
can be seen as an extension
of this in three dimensions.
Instead of two
microphones, we're
talking about four
microphones now--
an omnidirectional
microphone and three
figure-eight microphones.
Then you combine these
in different ways,
similar to mid-side stereo,
to create virtual microphones
on the sphere.
So we can hear audio as
it is in front of you,
to the right of you,
or anywhere else
and we can smoothly rotate
between these positions.
And ambisonics is also
based on a concept
called spherical harmonics.
And the idea behind
spherical harmonics
is we're trying to approximate
a spherical function, a function
on the surface of a sphere.
So each of these
morph spheres you
see is called a
spherical harmonic,
and each one of
those maps directly
to an ambisonic audio channel.
That's a channel
of ambisonic audio.
And the lobes that
you see, the shapes,
they're similar to microphone
directivity patterns.
The microphone
directivity patterns
tell us the sensitivity
of a microphone
to sound coming from
different directions.
So the omnidirectional
harmonic here
is sensitive to sound
uniformly from all directions,
whereas the left-right
component is
more sensitive to
sound from the left
and right than it is from
the front-back or the top
and bottom.
So just to recap.
The idea behind
ambisonics is we're
going to take the entire
spatial audio scene, no matter
its complexity, no matter
the number of sources,
no matter what the
environment is.
Then we're going to collapse
that down into an approximation
and we're going to break
that into separate components
to represent that approximation.
Then in real time
on the client, we're
going to combine
that approximation
to create virtual
microphones on the sphere.
And this allows us to hear
audio in any direction
so we can respond to viewer
head rotation in real time.
So first-order ambisonics
is pretty great.
It really increases
immersion, and you start
to feel like you're there.
But there's room
for improvement.
With first-order
ambisonics, there's
a fairly large margin of error.
Pinpoint audio sources
don't sound so pinpoint.
They're widened and it's
hard to actually locate
a source perfectly without
a visual cue to guide you.
So our solution here
is spherical harmonics.
So as I mentioned before,
spherical harmonics
is mathematically based and
it has this nice property,
this infinitely extensible.
So we can choose
our cut-off point.
If we want only one
harmonic, we can
do that-- the
omnidirectional component.
Or if we want four or for
first-order ambisonics,
we can do that as well.
Or if we want 16 components
of audio, we can do that,
and that's called
third-order ambisonics.
And that actually starts to
sound pretty freaking great.
There's a dramatic
increase in quality
over first-order ambisonics.
Things sound crisper, more
precise, just better overall,
and it increases
immersion even further.
However, I haven't
even talked about how
to stream ambisonics
to the client, so let's
take a look at
that for a second.
So, again, our goal here is
spatial audio for everyone.
No matter where you are
in the world or no matter
your bandwidth or
device, we want
to stream spatial
audio to you and we
want you to have that great
cinematic VR experience.
However, traditional
audio technology
is not built for ambisonics.
It's built for stereo audio.
And this is great
for the past where
stereo audio makes
a ton of sense,
but in VR it's
decreasingly making sense.
So we wondered, is there
some existing technology
that we can repurpose
to stream ambisonics?
And there is, and it's
called Vorbis, which
is a free and open audio codec.
So we take first-order
ambisonics,
omnidirectional--
up-down, left-right,
and front-back spherical
harmonic components.
And then we stuff that into
a quadraphonic layout--
front-left, front-right,
back-left, and back-right.
And this actually
is pretty good.
Multichannel Vorbis support
is great across a number
of platforms, and this
helps us hit our goal of VR
for everyone.
However, this isn't ideal
for a couple of reasons.
Ideally, with ambisonics we want
a different bit distribution
than what we have right now.
With the quadraphonic
layout, we have a uniform bit
distribution, so each
of the audio channels
gets the same number of
bits allocated to it.
However, with
ambisonics, we like
to dedicate more bits to
the omnidirectional channel
than we do the others because
encompasses the entire sphere
so it's used all the time.
And for higher-order
ambisonics, it's
not really clear
how you're going
to do that with the
traditional codec.
The data rates get pretty
crazy, and we're not really sure
that that's going to help
hit our goal of streaming VR
spatial audio for everyone.
So we're working on it.
We're working on higher-order
ambisonics compression
using Opus, which is a free
and open, modern audio codec.
So what higher-order
ambisonics streaming via Opus
will allow us to do is stream
high-fidelity spatial audio
to more people,
getting more ears,
than we can today at
significantly lower data rates.
So I've talked about streaming
spatial audio and what
spatial audio is, but I haven't
gone into creation at all.
And I actually won't go into
creation very much today.
We have resources
online for that.
But, in general,
creating spatial audio
is hard and creating VR
video in general is hard.
Today it requires
a number of tools,
and the iteration
cycles are pretty long.
So we're working
on that as well.
We've developed Jump
Inspector, which
is an Android app
for Cardboard which
allows you to preview VR videos
with spatial audio in real time
on your Android device.
And Jump Inspector also
has a great feature
for spatial audio producers
called Jump Inspector DAW
Integration.
And what that allows you to
do is sync Jump Inspector
to your digital
audio workstation
so you can mix in real
time and preview VR
video on your
device in Cardboard
as you're mixing, as
you're adjusting levels.
Anything you do in the mix is
rendered in real time in sync
with Jump Inspector,
and it's pretty great.
And lastly, if you want to
check out spatial audio today,
you can.
Just go to the YouTube 360
channel on your Android device,
pop it into Cardboard,
have a listen,
let us know how it goes.
And now back to Husain
to talk a bit about what
we're doing for fostering
a healthy VR ecosystem.
Husain.
HUSAIN BENGALL: Everything
we've talked to you about today
so far-- our investment
in Jump to make VR video
creation easier,
playback improvements
through adaptive
projections, and our work
on spatial audio-- all of
these are rooted in the belief
that VR video done well and
delivered at a high quality
can make some of the most
powerful VR experiences
possible today.
There's one more thing I
want to talk about-- formats.
We believe having an open
and easy-to-use format
is critical to success
of the ecosystem.
It's been great to see that
one of the formats we published
in 2014 has gotten recently
a wide amount of adoption.
We've also received a
lot of feedback though.
And we've taken a lot of
that feedback into account
and published a greatly
simplified version
of the format at our GitHub
repository earlier today.
You can find that,
along with instructions
on using Jump Inspector and a
pointer to a discussion group
where anyone can provide
feedback on our format,
at that URL.
At Google, we're committed to
an open and strong VR video
ecosystem, VR
video for everyone.
With that, I'd like to wrap up.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
My co-presenters and I
will be sticking around
to take questions offline.
Otherwise, enjoy the
rest of I/O. Thank you.